the death toll from covet 19 is  approaching a grim milestone  4 million deaths globally the john  hopkins university tracker has  us just under that number here in the  u.s we had about  600 000 deaths while the race to  vaccinate is ongoing the virus continues  to spread and mutate  president joe biden wants to start a  door-to-door outreach  we discussed how the delta varian is  already responsible for half of  all cases in many parts of this country  it's more easily transmissible  potentially more dangerous well the  number of cases nationwide is up by nine  percent and several states are seeing a  dramatic surge  that includes in nevada where there are  449 new cases  more than double the 204 in june